[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships you can give us a call the
number is triple
8825 5225 I'm Jade warshaw and I'm
joined by bestselling author Rachel Cruz
I know we've talked about this Rachel
but I haven't gotten to talk about your
book that just came out I'm glad for
what I have thank you yes it launched
this week my new children's book my
first one ever and yeah it's doing great
it's so cute I love it it's been so fun
it was a fun process and hopefully that
message of contentment yes can be all
through our households with us with
little kids I'll be reading it to my
kids for sure so give us a call today uh
we'll take calls about your life and
your money and if you're interested in
getting this book you can can pick it up
where
Rachel uh ramsy solutions.com store or
anywhere books are sold that's right
love that all right let's go straight to
the phone lines we've got Stacy from
Manchester New Hampshire what's going on
Stacy hi it's nice to talk to you guys
um I'm actually looking for what I'm
calling a ramze rebuttal uh my husband
and I my husband and I are about to
we're very close to paying off our house
we have about 15,000 left and my parents
are always advising us not to pay off
our house cuz they tell us you know if
anything happens and if somebody sues us
then they can take our home from us and
it's not it's not going to deter me from
paying off the house but I'd like
something really smart that I can say to
to prove her wrong or something if I can
well you have homeowners
insurance yes we do who does she think
is going to sue you and take your house
who is she concerned about I don't know
she just my parents are very much uh
they they think that people are very Su
happy and they are they're not wrong but
so happy and stuff what's our net worth
um I'm trying to figure out if you have
a Target on your back is is what I'm
asking no definitely not definitely not
we're we I think we make
92,000 after taxes and our net worth is
probably about 200,000 we're sort of at
the beginning of everything I'm just
confused Stacey do they have something
that happen to them or someone they know
that someone like
like taking someone's house I mean
getting sued in general is a thing sure
but they would still they could still
take Equity I mean that if with that
logic that means you wouldn't try to pay
on anything and have no you know no
assets at all because afraid someone's
going to take the asset like that's no
way to live right yeah I know that's
what I said I'm like okay well I I'm not
going to stay in debt forever just
because of something that might happen
right cuz there's a lot of things that
might happen um but I was like I'm just
G to get somebody else's viewpoint on
this because like I said it's it's not
going to deter us we're going to P it
off because I don't want to I don't want
to owe anybody money anymore yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean and a good
umbrella policy will usually cover
things like if someone falls on your
property and tries to sue you or
something you know I mean there's like
Jade said there's insurances and things
to be put in place to protect you guys
from something like that but I'm also
concerned about how much uh they're
speaking into this like it's very
interesting that they do you guys talk a
lot about with
them um I talk a lot about money with
anybody who will listen that's fair
that's fair it's kind of my favorite
topic um you know because and I'm just
excited about you know how we're just
moving along with things but um my my
dad was a contractor his whole life and
I think that there were a couple of
times where you know people turned
around and maybe tried to him uh you
know and they you know was probably like
they were lying about things so but I'm
sure he was licensed andur
he was liced and insured and if
something came that's what that's there
for right yeah exactly yeah and I think
this is all out of fear on their behalf
for us you know it's fine they're my
parents but I was like hm I feel like I
could get a more expert opinion on this
because me just being like no Mom don't
be weird is probably not a very good
resp I mean yeah at the end of the day I
I love what Rachel said because it's
true if you go through life like that
then you're never going to have any
assets because you're just worried that
someone could take them away from you
and in this Cas typically Rachel I think
we do umbrella Insurance once you get to
like a half a million net worth and then
from there on you could I mean if you
don't have a policy I think you're fine
once you hit 500,000 in net worth you
can pull one out and you can tell your
parents hey you know you can sleep at
night now I'm fully you know protected
in case someone wants to fall down my
stairs but I think honestly at this
point you're just fine like you're 100%
fine there's no target on your back um
and at the end of of the day if someone
wants to sue you they can sue you and
you would go through that process and if
you were at fault you were at fault and
if you weren't you weren't so it's like
this is a whole what if conversation
that's really hard to just speak about
because nothing's actually happened yeah
and it's that relational tension too
Stacy of going against something your
parents obviously have voiced so
strongly against and I think anytime as
an adult still you know even if you have
a relationship with your parents at any
level it is that feeling of like oh my
gosh and I had to learn you know God
love my my parents they're wonderful but
even certain things I'm like I had to
learn I can't control them I can't it's
not my job to change their mind about X
Y and Z and so really living in that
freedom of like you know Stacy you're
you're deciding this for your life and
and being so comfortable with that right
which I know you guys are because you
said it we're still going forward to pay
off the house but uh but I do
acknowledge just always that that's it's
an odd thing to be doing something that
your parents quote unquote
don't agree with or discourage or
something you know but I'm proud of you
guys for still going forward and wanting
just some facts but yeah you probably
won't change their mind even with a
umbrella policy answer uh and I think
that's where you kind of have to just
let it go you know I agree thank you for
the call Stacy that was a interesting
thing to talk about well let's see if we
can pop into New York right quick and
see what Donna is talking about Donna
from New York New York what's going on
hi hi there so I have a situation I L
was approved for a helck a home equity
line of credit through the same bank
that I have my mortgage through and they
gave me um an introductory rate for only
six months of
6.99 um percent but then after the six
months it goes up to
9.79 adjustable right yeah it's a helck
terrible idea Donna why are you getting
why are you taking out a
helck for several reasons so um so I
have about 60 ,000 in credit card debt
40 of that is legal fees um I have a
crazy family situation unfolding okay so
about 40,000 in legal fees 20,000 in
just regular credit card debt um and I
want to do some Home Improvements and
then also I was thinking about getting
maybe one or two income properties Don
how much Donna how much do you make a
year 125 pounds okay Donna do not take
this helck out don't take this out okay
you don't need to be doing home
improvements right now you have $60,000
in credit card debt that you Donna with
your income can clean up a HELOC doesn't
change that it actually puts you deeper
in a debt hole because of that and then
you're going to be taking out more than
what you need for this to do Home
Improvements and all of it you need to
slow down Donna do not take this helck
out it's not going to be worth it and it
has it's an adjustable rate you're going
to get terrible rates of return and then
you're stuck in it and you got to pay it
off if you ever want to sell the primary
property so hels are a terrible idea
Donna I would I would suggest the to um
to start paying off this de if you hold
on the line Donna I would love to give
you Financial Peace University this is
our nine lesson course on money and it's
going to give you the basics of
understanding how money works and
specifically with debt and debt is a
hard one to tackle because the way the
world does debt absolutely is not it's
not a good plan and so I want you to
watch these videos take this information
in and follow that plan not the HELOC
plan thanks for
calling this is is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need y refi they're not
a debt settlement company and they're
not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lump some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
all right you're listening to the ramsy
show I am Jade warshaw this is Rachel
Cruz give us a call the number is 8825
5225 and we will take your calls about
whatever it is you want to talk about as
long as it is related to your life your
money and in this case you know tell us
about your relation ships we can talk
about parenting a little bit we can talk
about girl
math it's a very real thing I know it's
a very real thing but give us a call
we'd love to talk to you in the meantime
we'll go to Miami we've got Caitlyn in
Miami Florida that's my neck of the
woods what's going on
Caitlyn hey Jade hey Rachel oh my gosh
my friend would be so jealous um because
he has such a big crush on you Jade it's
ridiculous that's so
funny so
great um let's cut to the chase okay so
I have a car loan um of $
4,629 left on that okay um I have
student loans of
$542 left okay and then I have a credit
card for
$39.49 like a
monthly uh subscription for okay um I'm
moving I'm moving moving in May to North
Florida okay um and I don't know what to
do as far as like how to pay this and
also like save to move um because I'm
new as far as actually following the
baby steps and stuff um so yeah so
what's causing you to move to North
Florida um my brother and his family
there um I'm a single mom and my son's
dad isn't in his life and so I strong
uh Ro male role model for him and my
brother is that so so just to be closer
closer to family and whatnot okay do you
already have a job in North Florida when
you get there um I've been working from
home for my current job okay got it okay
so what's your current income what's
it's at the end of the day this is just
a dollars and cense equation so what's
your current
income um around 50 okay and are you
currently on a budget at all or are you
just it seems like you know your numbers
pretty well so I'm just
wondering oh I just wanted to be
prepared so I didn't waste your time on
here um so I just started the every
dollar good um and I just noticed I've
been
spending stupid um like going out to eat
and stuff and I'm like trying to
actually so I just I just don't know if
I
should um focus on like paying extra for
my car in stud or if I should just save
for do you have any money KAIT do you
have any money that's not tied up in in
retirement or anything just just in
savings no Okay no Okay um and how how
much is the move going to be have you
have you run any numbers when it comes
to
that um no but I'm guessing like after
signing a lease and stuff it'd probably
be like 3 to
6,000 okay so in this case what I would
do is you you could approach this in one
to two ways you said you're moving six
months yeah and one way you could
approach it as kind of um a storm mode
where you're just stacking up as much
money as possible and then you move you
get there everything's calm everything's
good and then you start hitting this the
baby steps um because you have no money
saved the other side of this though is
and here's where I'm the side of the
coin that I land is it doesn't sound
like this is an urgent move and it
doesn't sound like it's something that
must happen in 6 months it sounds like
it's something you want to do and if it
were me probably get this debt cleaned
up first and then I'd feel the freedom
to move save up for that cost and you
know kind of do that in a much more
peaceful less under the gun feeling what
is what do you think about that because
my um I I mean I would agree um that
would be my first choice but my lease
ends in May okay will it be cheap and
will your to live and from just like a
standard of living premise will you be
will it be cheaper I'm assuming in North
Florida than Miami yeah much cheaper
yeah much cheaper there um like I'd
probably save a th000 in rent that's
great yep so I'm kind of I am I lean on
Jade's side of this Caitlyn I not that
you have to pause all um not not that
you have to pause moving necessarily but
in these six months I want you to gain
some traction because you're starting to
you feel that level of like oh my gosh
I've been out of control and now you're
seeing the numbers with every in the
budget you're like oh I am I am I've
been sending so you have some really
positive momentum in this direction of
getting control of your money and I want
to keep that going and so if I were you
Caitlin I would have the goal to try to
pay off well the $39 just do that
instead of go into Chick-fil-A tonight
with your kids right just just pay that
off right now um get that knocked out
and then I would try to work to pay off
the carh and and then have a little bit
of a nest EG for that move and I would
do that move as cheaply as possible and
I mean as like no because it's just you
and your son is that
correct yes yeah which is great and so I
would Kaylin I would make it a I would
be motivated to do it as as absolute
cheap as possible to get up there and
then when you're up there you're going
to be saving money you know on rent and
all of that and you'll be able to knock
out this student loan because honestly
Caitlyn you have $10,000 in in in debt
and I know that probably it feels
overwhelming maybe to you but Jade and I
as we sit here on this side of the table
we take calls all the time of people
that are in far worse situations with
debt so my belief and hope in you
Caitlyn that you can pay this off is so
great like it is so great and if you can
find a way to do some extra side work at
night maybe from home uh work extra Jade
always talks about getting your income
up and all that like you can you can
actually do a couple of these things
turn some knobs and you're going to see
real quick progress Caitlyn I really do
believe that there's also another thing
if you interested in paying off all this
debt before you moved you could check
with your landlord and say hey I know my
lease expires in May is there any way
that I can do a couple of more months
just month-to Monon cuz here's what
here's my goal and maybe just talk to
them and let and find out and in these
situations I want to get as much
information as possible so I know what
all my options are and then you can
really make the best decision for you if
if he says no look in May that's it
you're out then you know do what Rachel
said and it's like try to pay off as as
much as you can stack up some money do
this move on the cheap but you might
have more options than you know you just
haven't asked yet so it's worth it to in
my that's what I would do yeah for sure
yep yeah no that's great I actually
didn't even think of that so thank you
guys yeah especially if you've been
there for a long time like if you've
been a tenant there for a long time
you're trustworthy you've always paid
your rent on time if it's me there's no
reason why I wouldn't Grant the favor
because you're a good renter and I'd
want to keep that person as long as
possible especially if you came in and
then said hey if I can have like three
four months H uh month to month after
May and when I leave I have the perfect
tenant for you that's great that's a
great deal that's what I would do yeah
and Caitlin and remember your number one
your number one goal beside well if I
were you I'd pay the $39 credit card and
close it today so I just get that out
way but besides that making sure you
have that thousand emergency fund that's
going to be the very first step and
Caitlyn for you and your confidence even
doing that yeah getting $1,000 saved on
the side going from a hundred to a
thousand where you are I think that's
going to give you that peace of mind and
some that level of control of like okay
I know I know my plan and it's working
and it's working so I'm excited for you
Caitlyn I think you're going to do
awesome awesome and just a shout out to
all the single parents out there yes
it's I mean when you're when you're it
in every aspect of life and then and
you're taking care of a of a kid in the
middle of it too I'm like it's it's a
lot your mind is all over the place so
there's a little bit of that of course
of course you would be where you are
right so shame or embarrassment in that
um but the it makes a lot of sense
wanting to be by family yes for sure for
sure I get that I love it especially you
know family it's the Christmas season
this is my segue it wasn't a great one
but here we are uh getting meaning
meaningful gifts for Christmas during
our $12 sale this is what's in front of
me right now guys here at Ramsey
Solutions every year we do this amazing
$12 Christmas sale and you can shop for
best-selling books like The Total Money
Makeover uh baby steps millionaires even
books like own your past change your
future and they're just $12 I think
that's great uh questions for humans
conversation cards are as low as $10
right now plus the popular questions for
humans Christmas edition book is back
these sold out these sold out quick last
year wow I can't read uh there's a
meaningful gift for everyone on your
list so check out that sale today you go
to Ramsey solutions.com sstore and
you'll be able to find the gifts you
looking for for just $12 that's ramsy
solutions.com
sstore that's exciting that's why I'll
be doing some of my Christmas shopping
you can count on that that's good
awesome this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your Healthcare options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly 10 billion dollar in
healthcare costs chm is an affordable
alternative to insurance that gives you
the freedom and empowers you to live out
your values and you can join at any time
so find out more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget what's going on guys you're
listening to the ramsy show give us a
call the number is 8825 5225 and we will
chop it up with you I'm Jade warshaw
this is Rachel Cruz let's check out our
neighborly question of the day it says
today's question of the day is sponsored
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
when was the last time you thought about
your drri vent clogged dryer vents are
the cause of thousands of dollars of
house fires every year so let the
experts at dryer vent wizard clean yours
visit neighbor.com Ramsey to schedule
your service today well I know how to
schedule I I'll schedule them I'm ready
I don't I don't want that I don't want
that so today's question comes from Jim
in New Jersey what is the max amount of
time that you should hold off investing
for retirement while working baby steps
2 through three we've been working hard
on baby step 2 mostly student loans
since May of 2020 our finally pay our
final payoff uh we will be put off a bit
as we are welcoming our third child in
early 2024 I am starting to worry that
we are delaying investing for retirement
for too long any input would be helpful
um yeah and I think this is a great
question because it's true like if you
feel like oh my gosh I'm not
contributing to retirement and if you
know about compound interest and all of
it it may Fe this urgency may come over
you where you think oh my gosh am I
losing out on time yeah and the truth is
yeah I mean I guess you are if you're
not investing but your money is going to
something better you are getting out of
debt you are you are eliminating any
risk in your life you're saving up an
emergency fund of 3 to six months of
expenses after you do that and then
after that you have your entire income
at that point besides your mortgage to
be able to throw at investing and so
funding 15% of your income into
retirement especially if you're still
having babies because I'm assuming
age-wise yeah 20s 30s into your 40s
right so you still have some decades
there to be saving and so what the
problem is is that people try to do too
many things at once with their money and
they and they're spread thin they're
trying to throw some in a kids's College
fun fun and suon retirement here trying
to keep up with the you know all the
statements of all the debt and just
trying to you know payment on payments
there maybe throw some on a savings
account and it's just you don't get a
lot of progress when you do that and so
the intensity of paying off that debt
not only gives you Freedom financially
but it gives you like this emotional
spiritual Freedom too where you can
actually breathe and not have this risk
and this weight that you're carrying
around and then you have your whole
income to go and invest and what we find
people end up doing better yes they do
better when when this is the plan so I
understand the oh my gosh are we getting
behind you're not you're fine that
feeling is true but mathematically how
it ends up is that you're fine you'll be
fine when Sam and I started paying off
debt just the payoff just the baby step
two process was 7 and A2 years no no
investing then we needed to save our 3
to 6 months then we wanted to buy a home
and we needed to save up that money so
when I tell you during the time during
the course of that time whatever it is
he doesn't say um how many years it's
exactly going to be but what what's
going to happen is your income is going
to go up that's number one and so when
you finally get the chance to start
investing by large percentages you're
going to be investing more than you ever
would have during those other years no
don't get me wrong I missed out on some
time like that's just that is part of it
um when you have debt to pay off there
is a little bit of a consequence that
happens there and I do think that we
have to accept that as people who have
gone into debt and as people who are
having to come back and pay the piper
for that and I've accepted that I'm like
you know what I missed out on some years
but during that time I we worked our
butt off to make sure our income got up
so that when we did start investing we
would be able to make up for some of
that time that was lost and the good
news is most people are out of Deb in 2
years or less so they're never going to
have to face that but just know on the
other side of things we're doing just
fine is all I'm saying so you'll be
doing just fine as well so don't let
that hold you back it's good very very
cool all right let's see if we can take
some calls here let's go to Jacob he's
in Philadelphia Pennsylvania what's
going on in your world
Jacob good afternoon thank you for uh
taking my call you bet um my my question
was uh I'm kind of new to the show been
listening to it and um I have uh some
stocks from an employee purchase plan uh
from a college shop that I have uh I
have a car loan uh about 14,000 and um
getting one to get your input on cashing
out on the stocks and paying off the car
right away
or letting the money kind of grow in the
stock portfolio and just paying the
payments I've been pay in yeah so uh how
much money do you have in these
stocks uh it's the police stock
purchases about 50,000 and then I have
like uh index funds which like another
uh 16 so uh weighs about 70 70 on
average yeah good for you Jacob that's
great and you have no just liquid
cash uh about 20 in like an annual like
4% savings oh okay well
honestly I mean at that point I would
probably just take the 20 and pay off
the $4,000 car loan I would go the the
stocks single stocks are always it's
always a risky you know move there so I
almost would just move those anyways to
probably go back to that index fund that
you have is it just a Vanguard account
or what is
it um they're their S&P Index Fund okay
um yeah yeah so um so yeah so I would I
would probably get out I would get out
the single stock game put them in index
funds but I would use that 20 grand you
had to go ahead and pay off your car how
much do you make a
year uh it's about um with my wife and I
it's about 35 uh 100 a month a month
okay so y'all are right at okay about 40
okay what's the purpose of those index
funds what what were you stocking that
money away for
for um it was just kind of um it was
like uh I got advice you know you put
10,000 away and you know over 20 years
it should be you know
400,000 is um if if it's the annual
growth is 20% but it's non
retirement it's just a
brokage correct uh but I do also have um
a raw 401K uh from this previous
employer that's like another 40,000 and
are you consistently contributing to
that no I work on um I work in a
different uh area now so I haven't been
uh contributing to that and that's kind
of where I put the uh index I was
putting money into the index fund I
whatever I got like a yearly bonus or
some like extra money on the side I'd
like to give you some I'd like to give
you a bit of a clearer picture of how
you're using your money is that is that
okay cuz I'm listening to you talk and
it kind of sounds like there's some over
here there's some over here I have this
but it's not working together as
efficiently as it could yeah tot yeah
absolutely so if I were you and this is
the framework that we use for everybody
that calls in and it works for everybody
if I were you um I would do what Rachel
said which is I'd take that 20,000 that
you have that's liquid I'd pay off your
car right do you have any other debt
laying around or it's only the
car uh consumer it's the car and then uh
a house switches like I have about 139
uh remaining okay awesome so once the
car is clear you're Consumer Debt free
and then you've also got 6,000 left I
would take that 6,000 and put pull out
whatever other money out of some of
these stocks and I would make sure I
have 6 months of expenses set
aside then after
that go ahead I'm sorry um in my mind
like uh when I was thinking about the 4%
annual um that 20,000 that's where I was
kind of like listening to uh the steps I
kind of consider that would be like my
36 month well it would be but the first
thing you've got to do is pay off your
debt that's thing one once the debts out
of the way you can stock back up money
in a similar I mean you can use a high
yield savings account you're still going
to get 5% so that's great but the idea
is right now I feel like you've got this
money in stocks and S&P 500 accounts
where it can be used in a better way so
that what I'm suggesting is paying off
that debt saving up 3 to six months in a
high yield savings account and then what
I would do do you have
kids uh just just got out of two under
two but yes uh two young ones okay so
then after you guys have already got a
house so you've already done that whole
thing but the next thing is I'd start
putting some of that money away in some
529s for them so you and your wife can
decide a certain amount chunk some over
for uh baby number one chunks some over
for baby number two and then whatever
you have next I would throw that at your
mortgage and that might leave you go
ahead I have about 4,000 uh and for for
both of them set aside right now okay
and are you goast 529 that's great are
you actively adding to it or you're fine
with
that um I've been kind of just uh uh
been uh putting cash aside in the past
like couple months the point I'm trying
to make is I want you to be making
really clear really um intentional
decisions about how you spend this money
I don't want you just saying I'm going
to make a big chunk of it over here
because it's not working best for you it
sounds like the things that are
important to you are your kids education
it is having money saved and it is
paying off debt we're just going to give
you the most efficient way to do all of
those things and in the end you should
be investing 15% of your income every
single month out of your paycheck once
this debt is paid off so that's what
we're trying to get you to this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
/
[Music]
Ramsey you are listening to the ramsy
show I am Jade your host I'm joined by
bestselling author and host of The
Rachel Cruz show Rachel Cruz and we are
taking your calls all afternoon long
your life and your money give us a call
the number is 8825
5225 let's go directly to the phone
lines we've got Matt in Albuquerque New
Y uh Albuquerque New Mexico not New York
what's going
on hi uh yeah I just kind of wanted to
run by uh my car purchase with you and
see if I made an irresponsible purchase
I don't think so oh this is fun Matt
this is fun pop quiz time we'll tell you
true or false yeah if you financed it
I'm probably gonna say true but let's
let's talk about it what's going
on so I needed a car because I had a car
that I ran into the ground I put like
275,000 miles on it and it needed a
$55,000
repair but the car was only worth maybe
a th000 bucks at this point and so I got
rid of it and I decided to get something
new reliable that um I work a lot and I
just the unforeseen not having a car
just doesn't work for me there's a lot
of caveats here already but keep going
yeah yeah sure and um so I decided to
get what I wanted and it wasn't too
expensive but from where I come from
like I for a long time in my life I was
a drug addict with nothing right and I
was never used to having any money and
now um you know I waited tables to put
myself back through school and end up in
a career thank you thank you I'm seven
and a half years clean that's great
congratulations thank you thank you and
so I decided to you know treat myself
and get the car that I
wanted and so what' you spend still kind
of I spent um after down payment the
amount financed is 26,000 okay how much
do you make a
year um after taxes I take home about 96
Grand okay good for you what are you
doing now workwise thank you I'm a pipe
fitter okay good for you well Matt
you're impressive in general I think the
idea of beating addiction or being in a
certain lifestyle and then completely by
your own mission just completely
changing your life around is the is the
biggest thing ever right car payment or
not like people like you that do that
it's it's remarkable absolutely
remarkable and I find that you know with
a story like that or even we talk to
people we talked to a lady yesterday who
she battled cancer and she got over it
but she went and purchased you know a
new car she wanted for the S like
there's a there's so many emotions tied
to money and there's this level of
Celebration or this level of like I
finally like like I I don't want to
drive the crappy car anymore like I want
a break give me a break life give me a
break like it's been tough right so so
that emotion is is very real it doesn't
um eliminate the mathematical side of it
right regardless of why we purchased it
there is still debt in the picture so um
so yeah I would it's not an insane
number compared to your income like if
you were making $330,000 I'd have to
tell you you have to sell this but you
could probably pay it off pretty quickly
do you have any other debt at all
besides just the
car um on my house I I purchased the
house and um I have about 880,000 left
on the house I'm chunking it away as
fast as I can yeah good for you so do
you have any savings right
now um liquid cash about 12,000 okay
awesome um yeah go ahead I have a I have
a
401k um where my company puts in 5% of
my income and then I put in um 15% on
top of that okay and the the eight grand
a month is after I put in the 15% as
well like that's just my take home okay
awesome um good for you and I'm Union so
I don't have to pay for healthare I
don't have to pay for any of that that
take home is my money that I just get to
do with as I please awesome that's great
okay so what I would do Matt is I
honestly in your position I would pause
that 15% going into retirement for now
get some of that cash back in your
paycheck I would take 11,000 you're not
going to like this but I would take
11,000 of that savings bring it down to
$1,000 I would throw
11,000 at this car and at that point
you're going to have $155,000 left in
car debt and I would do whatever I could
between now and April give yourself a
timeline kind of map it out and say if I
work extra if I work nights if I drive
Uber if I like go crazy for about four
to five months knock the rest of this
out and then save up more on top of that
,000 to a 3 to 6 months um of expenses
in an emergency fund and you can do that
by fall of next year and then press play
again back to your retirement then and
be funding your 401k so you're really
just going to pause it I'm making up
timelines you wouldd have to run your
own numbers but you know for a year
maybe pausing retirement to get this
debt paid off to get an emergency fund
back into place and and then you're well
on your way at and then your mortgage is
80 grand and if you start yeah putting
more towards that even you're going to
pay that off really quick and Matt
you're going to it's going to be a a
whole new world for you but I would I
would I would do what I could to pay
that that car debt off um as soon as
possible yeah that's what I'm thinking I
I think I could get it paid off
comfortably in the next I mean if I take
that money out and I put it towards a
car probably six months yeah I can get
it paid off easily yep for sure I know
and then I would say too don't do it
comfortably maybe it's really
uncomfortable and you do it in four
months right like you you do some stuff
that you really do sacrific just do it
are you are you single
married um I have a girlfriend but no uh
like Financial anyone else yeah that's
great so I think now I'm like this is
the time it's the time just to do it
because the other power mat and and go
to ramsy solutions.com and look up our
investing calculator I think this is
always fun especially with a car payment
because it's a depreciating asset uh
throw your car payment in an investment
calculator and just say from now till
I'm 65 like how much could that be at
retirement I mean cuz Matt you're you're
well on your way to becoming what what
we always say is baby steps millionaire
yeah um so it's powerful and and who you
are Matt and your the story you told us
at the beginning I'm like oh yeah this
is like this is a piece of cake if you
can get over if you can tackle an
addiction like this car thing oh yeah
this is nothing I mean this is this is
four months of Lifestyle sacrifice and
some extra you know work right on top of
your job like you can do this but I
think that I'm I'm pretty used to being
uncomfortable yeah yeah you would have
to be I'm looking at these numbers how
you turn turned your life around and
that's just unbelievable to me how old
are
you um I'm 29 29 okay way to go good for
you that's awesome well thanks for
calling Matt uh I hope that gives you
some Direction but again uh that's a
real thing Jade of that's where we
always say money is never just about
money there's there's so much more
underneath that is kind of churning that
causes us to do the things we do with
money I wrote a book called know
yourself know your money all about this
because I'm like whether it's your
childhood how you were brought up uh the
life you're living today your fears your
dreams your natural god-given
personality and tendency uh environment
I mean all of this shapes why we do the
things we do with money and so for him
I'm like yeah the the idea that you know
you you climb this Mass massive Mountain
personally um and what he was dealing
with you know there there is that
feeling of like goly I I deserve a good
car like this is what I've done and
there I it to myself yeah and I get that
right you don't want to drive the crappy
car but also that doesn't eliminate the
financial ramifications right that come
with it so being debt free gives um
freedom in another part of your life
that's right in that money side and
luckily he didn't go too far off the
rails like I was expecting him to be
like I spent $50,000 and bought a you
know an Escalade so he he kept it
somewhat reasonable luckily he'll be
able to pay it off in the next year um
if it was more than that though we might
have given him different different
advice but yep I know selling the car
and and for all you listening it um and
this isn't to pick on Matt by any means
but just in general the car debt for me
Jade is the one that hurts the most when
people call in because I'm like okay
credit cards you know some people are
doing it to keep up with their bill like
you you you you can to a point be like
okay there the student loan thing we all
know why you know people fall into that
trap all the time uh there's certain
parts that you can kind of see but it's
the the card DEET one always gets me
because of the amount people pay in
payments we actually did a video
together or saw a video together people
and it was like $1,200 a month and one
car that's going to car payments and
you're just thinking no and I'm not even
overly math nerd but I'm like you invest
that instead let that work for you than
the car dealership or the bank like it's
it's crazy so it's great the car payment
it what it's what keeps the middle class
middle and it's what keeps you broke so
make sure to get those cars paid off
it's not worth it a pay payment the rest
of your life when you could use that
payment to become a millionaire which is
what Rachel Cruz so eloquently said that
does it for this hour of the ramsy show
check us out next
[Applause]
[Music]
hour
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Ramy personality
Rachel Cruz is hosting this hour with
bestselling author and Ramsey
personality Ken Coleman so give us a
call it's a free call anywhere in the
country at
5225 so first up we have Damon here in
New York City hey Damon welcome to the
show Hi how are you Dave doing we are
doing great how can we
help so I made
a decision about two years ago that ha
me up until today okay where me and my
family we were renting and um we decided
that we were going to purchase a house
together and we all put like maybe like
10,000 each to get like 50,000 to put
get the
house and the house was
420 and at a
2.8% so ever since we moved to the house
I haven't lived there because I was
still going to school and I was still
commuting spending maybe up to 500 per
month in
gas and
um we decided that we were going to we
made a verbal agreement that we were
going to continue to pay even though we
don't live there anymore and I realized
how bad of a decision that was and I
want to tell him that um I can't
continue to pay this anymore but knowing
how my family is I know Thanksgiving is
not going to look the same for me if I
tell them this and I don't know where to
go and I haven't been able to sleep I
just stare in space all day like I don't
know what to
do oh my gosh okay so who all when you
say your family is this like your
parents and siblings or who does this
what who do what makes up this parent
parents and siblings parents and
siblings and is someone renting this
house right now since you all aren't
living in it
we we all are living in it but we all
put together to contribute to the morage
and the
bill but in the past year I haven't
lived there and I've been paying
religiously non-stop every month towards
the bills 600 and another 100 towards
like utilities but 600 tours mortgage
and so you're renting somewhere
else I'm living with friend cuz it's
closer to my job okay but I'm not able
to save and my student loans are about
to kick in and I have credit card and I
just don't know what to do well sure you
do you know exactly what to do th this
is you said you're in a fog I'm using my
words you said you just stare into
nothingness all day long I mean this is
absolutely shutting you down you're not
going to be able to live forever with
your with your friend you're going to
get kicked out of that eventually this
is slowly breaking you down you know
exactly what to do you have to sit down
with your parents and your siblings and
say I know I gave you a verbal agreement
but here's what my life is and here's
how I got there student loans you you
show them everything I can't afford to
pay you $700 a month and they're going
to say Well then why don't you live here
and you go I don't want to live here and
you're going to tell them all the
reasons why you don't live there and
it's going to suck but you're going to
have to choose your own livelihood and I
mean like as in living well-being you're
going to have to choose you
and you're going to have to have a big
boy conversation and own it if they get
mad at you for a while and Thanksgiving
sucks I would rather have a sucky
Thanksgiving or two or three than a
sucky
life yes yeah and I think and I also
think it's fair because on their end
they're thinking yeah well we've agreed
to this and you're understand and you're
and you're breaking that but Damon but
to Ken's point it has to like this
doesn't sustain this you can't you can't
live like this so I think that even
saying I understand I'm backing out of
what I said but I I don't even have the
I don't have the ability I don't have
the ability anymore to do this and so if
there's something else I can do to maybe
help but I I think to Damon like I think
owning it is is um a very humble thing
to do and I would do that but also for
your sake and I would hope your I would
pray your parents which I always think
the best about relationship I'm always
like you're I'm sure your parents are
wonderful so you would is going to be
wonderful you would pray that your
parents would say yeah we see this in
our son we see the numbers and the
situation and we don't want to put that
on our side how old are
you I'm 30 how old were you when you did
this
deal um 28 okay so was just two years
ago do they find it like was the was
there going to be a point that you guys
would have this like paid off and I
would split the equity like what was the
plan the plan was cuz we moved to
America the plan was just to have
somewhere to live and have a family home
and everyone contribute will this put
them with your parents do you know the
math of when you do choose to stop
paying will they still be able to cover
the
payment there there are enough adults in
the house
where they will be able to cover the
payment if I stop paying they would be
able to pay like maybe 200 extra you
know they would just have to adjust
their spending habit yeah but one of my
siblings already cut Communications with
me attempting to have a conversation
about this and that's the kind of person
they are yeah I'm sorry about that I
don't make light of that but it it I
mean you have no choice you either
choose to not have an awkward situation
with them or you choose to have an awful
life and and that's and can I say if
they choose to cut off communication
with you because of this that's
that's their choice yeah you can't you
can't control that and it's would be one
of the most
painful terrible scenarios when there's
fractured relationships in life I think
it's just I mean there's there's grief
in that I mean it's it's
terrible um but but you didn't choose
that you still want relationship with
them you just can't make a $700 payment
to a house that you don't live in
anymore and that's what you're asking to
be out of not out of the family um and
so if they choose to take a different
route sadly that that is on
them yeah where did you where did you
guys where did you guys move from where
you guys from
originally we moved from um New Jersey
to New
York but before you said we came to
America oh we moved from uh the
Caribbean okay because I do know too you
know that certain level of loyalty in
your word and certain cultures right
right holds way more weight than others
right so I I know that that sometimes is
at play as well um but I do I I would
own what I what I signed up for and that
I can't fulfill
it but them choosing to not communicate
with you anymore that's that's their
stuff right and if it's not this and if
those are the kind of people they are I
hate to say it there's going to be
something else in life you marry someone
they don't agree with you raise your
kids a certain you know what I mean like
yeah eventually that that happens but
I'm so I'm so sorry Dam you aren't a bad
person I I think you were calling for
permission we don't have the power to
give it to you but I I will tell you
that we're in agreement on what you
should do and so are you and you need to
do this you're not a bad person for
doing this and I think you need to give
yourself some forgiveness for not living
up to what you agreed to and knowing
that you got to make a different
decision which is the right decision so
do it and move
forward
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation
plus there are never any misleading
quotes or hidden fees everything's
backed by their 100% satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
seey blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
visit blinds.com to get up to 45% off
that's blinds.com rules and restrictions
May
apply
[Music]
[Applause]
so if you haven't heard yet uh mint
which is a large budgeting app Feature
uh that has over four million budgeters
is closing at the end of the year and
we've been in the personal finance space
for over 30 years and we know budgeting
is such a crucial part to your financial
picture so we have had every dollar our
budgeting app out for years and it's
fantastic and so now that we know
there's be four million people out into
the world that don't have a budget we
just wanted to remind you guys to make
sure to check out every dollar there's a
free version that you can download you
can download the app or go to Every
dollar.com and the premium version is
worth it it is worth it we have some
different deals that are going on we
even have some every dollar webinars
that we do to actually coach people and
show people how to budget and what this
looks like and you can go to uh
everydollar.com
I think budgeting for that webinar uh
but make sure yeah to check out to check
out every dollar budgeting again is a
crucial part to you winning financially
and with mint closing again there's
going to be millions of people that need
a budgeting app so make sure to check
that out all right let's go to the
phones this hour we got Dale in San
Antonio up next hey Dale welcome to the
show thank you so much for taking my
call I really appreciate it absolutely
how can we help so I think your screener
kind of help me figure out what my
question really is and that is um I've
I've got a I've got a good income uh I'm
working really hard to be 100% out of
debt although with my mortgage and being
um 63 years old I'm not sure that I'll
ever make that happen 100% but I'm going
to work on it and uh the biggest
challenge I think I have is uh getting
my wife on board with all of the aspects
of being completely debt free having a
real budget and sticking to it and
knowing where your money goes so today I
ordered the book uh Total Money Makeover
good of course I've been listening to
you guys um we had purchased a new car
in
2022 which um I'm more than doubling the
payments now so that I can get that paid
off as quick as I can I don't have any
credit card debt uh the only other debt
I have is we ended up putting in a pool
last year and so um working on get the
car paid off get the pool paid off and
then really hit the uh the mortgage um
luckily you know we have a a great
amount of equity in it but um about half
of my income every month goes somewhere
and I can't seem to find the way to get
my wife on board with knowing where it
goes and managing
that okay well getting spouses on board
I feel like is one of the more common
themes that we hear a lot and um I would
say sometimes the issue H more is waited
on that spouse that doesn't want to be
on board and sometimes Dale we find the
issue is actually the person that wants
to do all of this but they are maybe a
little controlling and all that I'm not
saying that's you I'm not saying that's
you um but I would ask when you do
approach these conversations what's her
what's her hesitation what's her um her
feelings are negative around it does she
Express
why um she doesn't really Express
negativity what she expresses is that
all of the purchasing that she's making
is for a reason yeah and that every
purchase that she's making is with is
with absolute a lot of research making
sure it's the best value for the money
Etc but when I walk into the house and I
see 15 boxes sitting there on the table
that haven't been opened yet and I'm
wondering what is all of that um most of
the time if I'll ask her something
specific uh about well what is is that
she said I'm not sure I need to check
because um I I I think that's her
full-time
job full time job okay so there's a
couple things she spends a lot on the
family yes and you know and what we find
a lot of times is that in a
household sometimes not always it's a
little stereotypical but it just ends up
being true for a lot of people is that
the is that the woman is the one that
usually is kind of the CFO of the
household meaning she's the one that's
kind of keep keeping track of the paper
towels and the toilet paper and who
needs a Costco run and who needs to do
this right like like the that
functioning aspect um not always but a
good amount of time is on the woman and
so I'm sure that's the role that she has
played uh to a degree and so I would I
would say Dale you know sometimes it
could feel because I'm more of the
spender my husband's more of the saver
so I actually in some ways May relate to
your wife it's getting a package in the
mail and I'm like oh let me check the
Amazon app I can't remember what I
ordered so uh so I get that to a degree
now I don't want her to be irresponsible
or lying or sneaking things around or
anything like that but I would say in
your language I would change the well
what did you buy what is this and it's
things pointing at her and talk about
you talk about Dale and say man you know
sit sit her down and just say hey I'm
genuinely fearful that we're not going
to have money to be able to retire to
live the life we want this debt on the
pool
are cars like I'm starting to feel the
weight of this I'm feeling overwhelmed
I'm feeling stressed like it you're
speaking to you and what you're feeling
and that's one of always my piece of
advice for couples is to say your why
what is it and for some you know women
that I talk to out there it's you know
that they have to go to their husbands
and say well you please help me with
this because I'm scared if something
happens we're not going to be okay right
like there's always that
undercurrent that is happening that's
causing you to say oh my gosh I have to
order The Total Money Makeover book oh
my gosh I need to figure out where our
money's going so so I would express that
to her not in a oh we're walking through
the fourer and hey I I feel like we
should figure this out a true sit down
really sitting down and saying I want to
map out the rest of our life we have two
to three decades ahead of us how can we
best do this together and and do this
and and really focus because I'm I'm I'm
fearful I'm scared you know whatever it
is Dale for you explaining that why and
then I think it's always helpful to have
a plan and just to show her and knowing
that she can change what she wants on it
but to map out some level of a plan just
to say hey I kind of just did a mock
budget here's kind of what this is
looking like for us to have some margin
to be able to throw out the car CU if we
do this the car can be paid off in 18
months or whatever and then we can get
the pool paid off by the time we're 65
and then we can do retirement there I'll
have to work another you know maybe five
extra years to make sure to get where we
are like at least do some of the leg
work and a plan and show her cuz
sometimes the accusation of well they
don't want to budget they don't want to
do this it's cuz they don't know what to
do it's all this theory in their head
but when they see facts on paper for the
not always but sometimes that's helpful
and when she hears from you when she
hears from her husband where you're at
you see a plan and the bigger
conversation too is Dale like I want to
work as a team it's been you over here
spending this it's me over here and I
just I want to do this together and
having that conversation does that make
sense it does and I'll tell you just to
give you one little piece um couple days
ago I took a a look at the mortgage and
I I figured out a way that I can pay it
off in seven years yeah and I let her
know about that and she was pretty
excited about it so yeah yeah I think
she's very much open to making it happen
I just don't know that um the budget
that she wants the we talked about a
budget and the budget that she wants I'm
not completely comfortable with I think
it's a little high and so I guess well
budget continue yeah okay so do you guys
have do youall have every dollar
premium we don't okay hold on the line
uh when we get done with this call
because we're going to give you a year
of that because I want you guys to sit
down together look at your income for
the month and both of you Dale both of
you sit down and plug in numbers and
have these conversations go line item by
line item and say hey for food and she's
going to say we need $800 for groceries
and you may be like what that's crazy we
only need 400 and she's say no no no
have you been have you haven't done this
let's look on average what we spend to
run this and this is what it is you know
so you need some reality too into her
world and what she's been seeing yes but
also she can't go and just spend
whatever she wants either Dale so
there's there's a balance that you both
have to bring to this so I like you say
balance Dale here's my advice I would
take the offer at the higher budget one
of the things we teach in budgeting is
it takes 90 days 120 days sometimes as
much as 6 months to get budgeting right
I would take this offer from her okay
I'll do this budget and it may be a
little high for you and you may have to
adjust some of your payments on the pool
and things like that but let's just get
a budget where we're in agreement and
then we begin to hey could we adjust it
this month I'd take what she's offering
right now and I'd work from that I think
she's offered you an olive branch I'd
take it that's good that's good okay
hold on the line Dale we're going to
give you a year of that absolutely
thanks for calling thank
[Applause]
you
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz hosting
today this hour with Ramsey personality
and bestselling author Ken Coleman and
the holidays are coming up you guys and
here at Ramsey we always encourage you
all to get some gifts that are going to
help people and we always do a $12 sale
every year so if you go to Ramsey
solutions.com store there's a ton of our
books I know baby steps millionaires is
there total money makeup over own your
past change your future I think some of
mine know yourself know your money I
think is in there um from paycheck to
purpose the proximity principle you want
a new year new career come on you know
my kids need shoes my kids need shoes I
appeal to you uh we're practically
giving these books away no uh it really
is a great unbelievable sale and our
tribe just Goes Bananas every year but
can I talk about this yes were you going
to well I was going to say and also in
the store not for the $12 Sal it's a few
more dollars more yeah but this kids
book this where's the camera there where
there we go I feel like David Letterman
remember he used to do that there it is
this is Rachel Cruz's new book it's
called I'm glad for what I have and look
at how adorable it is can you tell
people who's this little bear it's just
well they don't have names but they
don't have names no but the it's obvious
I haven't read it yet no it's fine it's
fine uh squirrel there's yeah squirrels
Bears there's whales there's octopuses I
mean look at the art look at the artwork
in this this is great it's like showand
tell time the illust Rubik's Cube in
there this is great Kelly I'm reminded
of David Letterman and his cuticle I
don't know if my cuticles are up to
shape but I remember you they would zoom
in so there those of you who remember
letter this is a great book and I'll
tell you why it's great because it
begins a very important conversation
about gratitude and contentment that
will eventually be a huge deal in how
they handle money and that's what I love
you're getting kids early just under the
core of what money's all about I know I
know you know parents out there if you I
always laugh cuz the Amazon catalog has
come to our house and my kids have
circled literally everything in the
catalog for Christmas and I'm just like
oh my gosh but it is it's just the stuff
and the excitement of stuff and I
understand that you know this I I wrote
a book called love your life not theirs
because the comparison game just getting
more staying on top of it all the
upgrades the bigger the better I'm like
it's the American way of life and what
ends up happening financially is people
go down the Avenue of debt to get that
and they end up in a lot of trouble or
on tional side you go down this and you
think okay if I just get this stuff I'm
going to be fulfilled I'm going to be
happy this is the thing that's going to
really scratch the itch and I'm going to
be okay I just need this thing and we've
all said that and we all know it's not
true but there's something bigger and
better out there uh I believe that
actually do does fulfill us on a deeper
level so we talk about that at the end
of the book but these little animals go
on adventure to find and it's easy to
read can I read just one little thing
here oh do it across the whole world on
the sunny Savannah an elephant said to
her Pops in her Nana
when I get a toy it's exciting and fun
like anything's possible Under the Sun
let's just tuck everybody I think I
think I think I saw Kelly not off there
and my my very soft melodious voice just
story time uh it's just wonderful though
it's really cute and it's a great book
it should show up under the tree
everywhere Across America this is what I
say Thanksgiving Christmas y'all ramsy
solutions.com it's called I'm glad for
what I have go get it congrats by the
way thank you Ken thank you all right so
we're go to the phones uh right now we
got got Josephine in is that Vermont hey
Josephine welcome to the show hello how
are you we're doing great how can we
help so I have a question about avoiding
lifestyle drift as my income goes up
um I am very frugal because I would love
to be able to not work past the age of
uh 50 and I'm on track for that
as long as I sort of freeze my spending
where it is now
and I'm always sort of torn because I
also would like to live a little better
sometimes I would like to can I can I
jump in Josephine can I jump in really
quick because I think for our audience
this will be interesting are you a part
of the uh fire movement or at least uh
On The Fringe of the financially
independent retire early is that what
I'm
hearing no I mean I know what you're
talking about but my concern I mean my
motivation is more that my dad died when
he was
54 and I'm I work really hard and I
would love it to be optional at least
you know maybe I'll work longer
but but it feels like you're at the
point now where you've got a touch of
that movement in you where you're
working so hard you just want to enjoy a
little bit of life and I just wonder if
there's not maybe loosen maybe loosen
the belt one or two notches sorry for
that man metaphor there but it's like
you're living so tight and you're
squeezed with your time because of the
money issue and the work issue and I
just wonder if you can still retire at a
young age uh but also enjoy life a
little bit I I I wonder what's going
what are you missing what what what
would you say to Rachel and I I wish I
could do this every once in a while what
what's being
sacrificed well I mean really nothing I
guess like I I live very comfortably um
but I guess I mean the thing that I sort
of there something go back and forth
about is a new car ah which I don't need
okay and I worry that I want it more
because of like comparing myself to
others than so we're just talking it
yeah what are you driving now
so it's a 2020 Mazda
SUV like the
CX7 the five the five yeah it's a great
little car W great for you K know Ken
knows his Mazda I well I watch a lot of
sports so the sport if you watch at
football the car commercials are like
all the guys are laughing yeah that's
the only reason I know that I'm not some
Car Guy funny um that's a nice car
though so yeah it's always great you
don't need you're right you don't need
anything else and you shouldn't be
jealous you got a nice car yeah and I
think Joseph there's and so let me say
this I I do um for your dad and his and
his Story how what what um what happened
at 54 that made that caused him to to
pass
away he had an accident at work okay oh
I'm so sorry yeah that's yeah that's um
that's tragic and traumatic and all of
that um when it's sudden like that so
what I would say is there's part of the
motivation possibly I don't want to put
words in your mouth part of the
motivation for you that wants to retire
at
50 is a little bit of this fear that may
not be a real in your life and I'm
sitting here next to Ken and I think for
I think the stars have a line today
because Ken is one of the best talking
about the value that you bring Josephine
to the world that work is not something
to escape but it's something that you
can actually enjoy and find something
that you find meaning from now I agree
with you I wouldn't want to be paycheck
to paycheck feeling like I'm still
scraping by and that I'm still so
nervous that I'm not going to be able
but at this point in your life you could
cuz how old are you I'm 32 Okay so at
this point in your life Josephine I mean
you have a solid 20 25 years past that
50 point 52 55 that you can put away
some serious money um save but more for
the reasons that are not completely
fear-based because I think part of
what's paralyzing you maybe with your
lifestyle is this fear of if I spend
then I'm not going to have enough to put
away and if I don't have enough to put
away if something happens to me you know
X Y and Z and I understand that you know
there's reality to everyone's stories
and everyone is on this Earth a limited
number of days and we don't know those
days but but for you I think there's
some freedom to give yourself to say
yeah I'm going to shoot for a goal but
the reason I'm shooting for the goal is
not out of fear but maybe out of
something else and I wonder if that
motivation is different if that feels
different and your expenses that if you
do get a bump and a raise and you're
still being wise and you're investing
15% of your income and you're out of
debt and you have some money Sav for an
emergency fund and you're doing all of
this that it gives you permission to to
give give some of that away and to save
some of it sure and to spend it and
enjoy
it so I just I I I would kind of focus
in on on that I think Rachel's on it
Joseph I think Rachel's got a great
point I think this is a mindset switch
here's what I'm hearing okay I'm gonna
say this really fast you tell me if I'm
right or wrong and I don't mind being
wrong okay you're Frugal by Nature
you're very disciplined by nature and I
think what's going on is you're just
dealing with normal comparison stuff
that I deal with Rachel deals with we
all deal with it cuz somebody in your
life has got a really fancy something
something something and it's it's a
whole lot sexier than a Mazda CX5 and I
think what's going on is is you're going
man I kind of want that but here's what
I want you to do when you start to feel
that way do you want what comes with
that fancy car that your friend can't
actually afford and they're dragging
around $750 $1,100 car payment that's
real I'm not making that up and I think
if you start to go would I want that
would I want to have to spend more of my
savings on that you start to go well
what would I have to do to have what
they have and I think you'll go ooh I
don't want that I think you're going to
be really happy with your awesome life
in Burlington Vermont you're killing it
Josephine keep
[Music]
going
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with hen
Coleman Ramsey personality and best fing
author and we're taking your calls at8
8255 225 up next we have Tyler in Mesa
Arizona great area outside of Phoenix
hey Tyler welcome to the
show Hello thank you so much for taking
my call absolutely how can we
help so my question is should I keep the
house my father passed away I have two
younger brothers and I'm trying to
decide whether or not it makes sense to
keep the house oh I'm so sorry Tyler
what
happened um he was very sick for a long
time and uh he um couldn't take it
anymore um he he ended his life on April
3rd oh my goodness I'm so so
sorry wow so what kind of situation is
the the rest of the family in about this
I you're the one on the phone but is
anybody else involved in this
decision so my my parents are divorced
um my
my I'm usually living with my mom with
my brothers my two brothers um they
moved out to Cass Grand where my mom
lives um recently after my father passed
okay um
they're they're shooking up I mean we
all are it's not a uh how old are you
guys Tyler how old are you and your
brothers I'm 20 um wow my younger
brother Cody is 18 and my youngest is 15
okay so they're still in the house or
they're still at home so they moved with
your mom how far away is your mom's
house from Mesa or from where your dad
was
living about an hour okay and where will
you be living Tyler will you be closer
to your mom over there or will you be
more near your dad's your dad's
house I'm still living at home um I'm
going to college okay so um but is that
home in the home that your dad had
no it's my mom's home so so you're all
with your mom you're all an hour away
from where your dad was did you all get
anything else uh as a result of his
passing anything else besides life
insurance or
anything so uh life insurance paid out
um about 90,000 however he set it up
incorrectly and half went to my mom and
half went to my aunt fortunately my aunt
is um a really great person and she she
gave she gave me the money um and and
for the benefit of my two brothers and
myself um and so that's been kind of
keeping the house afloat yeah
he
um he spent his money as it came in um
all like there was yeah every dollar he
got he kind of he used pretty much so so
have you been paying the house payment I
guess it's only been what three or four
months you've been paying the house
payment through the money that your aunt
gave
you yes so the the money my aunt gave me
um I mean and then uh he he was
receiving money monthly from a trust
created by his father okay um and
so there was $20,000 in the bank account
and my aunt gave me
45 we're down to about 28 and
everything's on time the house isn't
going to get foreclosed on yeah how much
is how much how much would the the house
how much is it um worth right now do you
know if you sold it what could you get
for it about 430,000 okay and how much
is on the
mortgage uh about 30,000 okay so it's
almost a lot of
equity yeah there's uh it's appreciated
a lot since he bought it okay um I know
what I would do Rachel I know I know
what I would do too Tyler I just want to
double check like does this house carry
any level of significance to you in the
sense that you want to keep it within
the family like did your grandfather
build the house like is there a is there
any emotional ties besides just that
your dad lived there I understand that
but is there any reason you would want
to live in this house for
you my youngest brother um really wants
to keep the House's we've years old
right but he's he's 15
um I mean the big thing everybody's
telling me to rent it out and that's not
a terrible idea I mean and it would it
would keep it would keep the house
afloat and we'd have a little bit of
money coming in um okay so Tyler so what
I would do and Ken I'm sure we're going
to be on the same page with this I would
sell it Tyler I would sell it it's an
hour away from where you are the renting
game is something that you guys do not
need to burden yourselves with at 20 18
and 15 years old
and the Beautiful Thing is Tyler you're
going to get
$400,000 of equity which is a huge gift
to you guys and being able to use that
whether it's for college a down payment
on a home that you want for yourself I
mean whatever can be used for this money
is really going to jump start your life
Tyler in this and for you know reasons
that I I just don't think is necessary
to keep a home that's an hour away from
where you're going to be living and I
understand that's so emotional that's
why I kind of even wanted to ask that
first question of kind of what what
emotions are tied in this um because
homes especially when it it involves a
death we we hear this a lot Tyler it's
very difficult for people you know we
talk to people that and their their
spouse is passed away or parent and
letting go of that house feels like
they're letting go of them and there's a
a massive void there there's there's
another level of grief Al most of
letting something like that go but from
a financial standpoint Tyler I I would
sell it yeah I would it yeah Tyler I
would sell it too and for all the re
reasons that Rachel gave you you do not
in the moment of grief at this stage of
your life want to be dealing with being
a landlord and the amount of profit that
actually benefits you and your brothers
is limited to none at this point and I
know everybody's going oh it's an asset
you can blah blah blah blah no that's
not helping you at all versus selling
the house your dad's Legacy lives on and
the fact that he did pay the house down
and and and and he paid it to a point
where hey it's a huge set and split
three ways between the brothers I'm
assuming that's what the deal is that is
a massive massive massive uh Head Start
for you as Rachel said and I think it's
a no-brainer you do not want to mess
with this you guys can get into real
estate down the line but this could pay
for your 15-year-old brother's College
potentially uh this has so many benefits
and more importantly you guys need to
grieve you guys need to be able to
grieve without trying to figure out how
to deal with a landlord or somebody
who's going to operate the house when
you're gone your mother lives in a
different place there's just too many
unknowns and too many variables to think
that this is a good idea I would take
the money and invest it wisely I really
recommend Tyler that you at 20 uh as the
as kind of the older brother the man of
the house figuratively here uh i' get
with one of our smart investor of Pros
yes I say that and a u real estate ELP
and a real estate ELP and and but I get
the household and then sit with a great
investment advisor who will put that
money to work for all three of you
because even if we painted a different
scenario Tyler let's just pretend you
were 30 years old married with two kids
and you're like and I love this house
even if you kept that house you would
still have to pay out your brothers
because that's an asset that's split
between three people so again that could
be another conversation if you had the
money to do it and that's what you
wanted to do right so there's there's
different ways to do this but a really
clean way that takes a lot of pressure
off you a lot of work that is
unnecessary of having a rent are an hour
away that's going to be calling you at
2: a.m. because they're heating an air
broke in Phoenix and they're hot you
know I mean like it's just it's not
worth it it's not worth it at this point
and again like Ken said if you want to
get into that down the line I mean we I
come from a real estate family my
husband he's looking at doing flops now
I mean like we love the idea of real
estate and and uh having renters and all
of it but it has to be at a at a point
that it's not a stress point for you
that you're able to to have the cash and
the cash flow and I think that's with
season a life too Tyler and I hate to
like pin an age at you because of it but
I think you have so much life ahead of
you and this money again can be such a
gift to continue your dad's Legacy and
that's how I would look at it and to say
that you're selling yes an asset that he
had but man you're able to use that and
and put it in the market put it in high
yield savings go forward I just got an
idea you and Winston need a show on HDTV
if he starts flipping I want to see you
to walking through houses I want to see
you with a sledgehammer and your fancy
little shoes knock and drywall out that
America needs to see we need another
couple with a flip shot I like and it's
you and wday the air conditioning in
studios this is my job and I enjoy my
job thank you though Ken well thanks to
all the guys in the booth for making
this show happen Tyler thanks for the
call holding line we're going to you up
some stuff and oh and Kelly okay thanks
America this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
bestselling author Ramsey personality
and great friend Ken Coleman we are here
to answer your questions and it's a free
call anywhere in the country at
88255 22 2 five so we're going to go to
the phones this hour and we have uh Judy
up first in Indianapolis hey Judy
welcome to the show hi thank you so much
for taking my call absolutely how can we
help okay well this is my little
situation and I haven't heard this much
before on your show um I'm 59 and I'm a
widow and I'm unhappy in my present
position my job I've been in it since
2008 I
um have no debt I have um no electric
electric bills and uh I I have I can
live on very little a month I'm just by
myself I have no ears I have no
dependence it's just
me and I have um about 150k in a 401k
how much
150 yes okay and I have
75,000 in just a SA account high yield
ratings account and I'm like I said I'm
not happy in my present position what do
you do I'm a I'm in logistics
okay what makes you what yeah what
what's wearing on you is it the work or
is it the environment or
both well
um I'm a single employee employee for my
company on site at a customer and I been
there since like 2008 and recently my
schedules have changed all our all
team's schedules have changed where they
require you to be um on call for an
additional 48 hours a week but they
won't pay for the on call what they do
is you have as long as you can prove
your time spent in email time or or um
conflict management of uh shipments then
you can get your your time like 30
minutes a a night instead of you know
cuz I'm going call like five hours a
night and uh and you only get paid for a
small midon of that of
1% do yeah so that's just that just eats
away at you it's just irritating yeah I
get it and it's also your yeah and
you're bu yourself too I guess that's
not fun no so I I'm looking possibly to
change change my whole yeah whole life
you should you you should that's that's
what I'm getting at because Logistics if
you were in a different environment and
and different circumstances the
logistics work the the process nature of
it you probably enjoy that because
you're probably good at it is that true
or false I I believe I am okay good all
right call is what's killing me oh I get
it well first of all we need to be
looking to leave that would be my first
advice but but I guess you called for
some other reason do you do you know
what you want to do Judy yes yes I I am
looking um actually to um get a car and
um what I'm what I'm thinking is I want
to get a car with this part that about
30,000 of my 75 in savings and I I what
I want to do is is drive for a living um
whether it's LT or Uber or um senior
driving from errands and things like
that I think that's what I want to do I
want to help people that way okay now
now what do you making your well number
one do you have do you have any debt
Judy like just your no and house what's
your housing
situation I own my house full out like
outright you have no debt nothing okay
yeah she's like no you're living a dream
she told us she has hardly any expenses
so here's the question what are you what
is your current
car um it's right now it's a 2008 it's a
pickup a Toyota pickup and I won't get
rid of that I'm going to keep it I have
a small farm I I
chick and quail and rabbits so I'm going
to keep it for the feed and feed and the
dogs and stuff back and forth have you
done your homework on the Uber or the
lift have you done your homework to
figure out what you can okay and you can
make
plenty well I don't know about plenty I
don't take a much though I want to do
something I more enjy I get that I make
about 57,000 now all right well you're
not going to make 57,000 drive at Uber
oryt in Indianapolis all right so here's
what I want here's what I want to point
out I would just be very very very
careful about making this decision
because you admitted to me just a moment
ago that if I gave you a
$57,000 logistics job where you didn't
have that nagging issue of uh being on
call like a doctor and I can't leave
work at work and I'm not working in an
isolated situation that you would
probably enjoy that job didn't you tell
me something like that yeah I'm not so
sure I want to go back and forth to an
office anymore yeah okay fine with thats
um I get it I get it but I'm still
saying here's what happens let's say you
buy a car for $30,000 okay uh that car
is going to continue to go down in value
whether it's brand new or it's used and
you're driving around and you're not
making much now you're helping people
you sound like a lovely person who would
be awesome to talk to if I was in the
backseat of your car and you were
driving me around but this is not just
about you serving people by driving and
maybe you could get a delivery job where
you're making pretty decent money have
some job benefits I want you to find the
middle ground between Uber and Logistics
I just feel like you've got a too wide
of a either or here yeah CU what I don't
want to happen Judy is you look up in 15
years and you know you're 70 and you're
like I I want to be done and you look
you're like gosh but I don't know if I
feel comfortable being done yet because
of my Nest Egg so I want you to run some
numbers for you Judy and just to see
okay what would it look like to let me
go over a little bit more um I'm sorry
maybe I didn't make myself clear I'm a
widow so um I can get my husband's
Social Security at 67 or 72 but I I I'm
very healthy so I plan to work for a
while my husband's social security has
been estimated at 2700 a month at 60 if
when I turn 67 plus I have an annuity of
2221 already in place every month for
the rest of my life okay so
that would be 47 4800 a month which is
more than plenty for me to do stuff with
yeah and if I was to have if I was to do
Uber or lift or even drive for a senior
community um errands or whatever they
needed um I could call my own hours all
right I changed my all right Judy Judy
you're awesome you gave me new
information you gave me new information
I'm glad you gave me new information and
now I'm going to tell you go drive
yourself till you're just completely
content because I I now you got more
margin than I thought you had I didn't
want you at this young age and I love
that you said you're going to keep
working I think you got way more options
so I'm going to say go drive Uber or
lift or for senior citizens I changed my
answer yep do you think that's enough
for for me to live on I mean I don't
really I only have 150k and and that's
what I was a little concerned about I
want you to run those numbers you I'll
I'll waffle between my two answers first
piece of advice I gave you I think is
good but I also think that you're Frugal
enough that if you try this for a couple
years uh you can always make some
changes that's what I'm thinking yeah go
ahead and I would get out of the job
you're not happy there you have enough
margin today in the present to drive so
do it till 2026 and then kind of look up
and you know decide okay do I need to go
back into something more full-time for a
few years and make that call but for
today Judy I think you're good I think
you're good to go do what you want to do
thanks for the
call
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show up next
we have is it baa in Palm Springs is it
baa or
brda it's uh BR likes water purifier BR
yes nice perfect very nice thanks for
calling BR how can we help thank you for
taking my call um I got a quick question
I'm currently in baby step 2 I've paid
off 56,000 since January oh my
God you guys who I backed out of
bankruptcy to follow your guys's plan
and I it's best choice I ever made look
at you I'm so proud of you that's
amazing thank you thank you so all of my
debt was in collections when I started
so nothing had like a minimum that I you
know to keep it current none of it was
current I have one debt that's not
accepting payments right now because
they say they're not allowed to collect
in Colorado and California right now I
think they have a lawsuit going on maybe
oh interesting okay and then yeah I have
an $81,000 medical debt that is
obviously in collections and their
minimum payment that they're asking for
is $2,300 a month which would stop yeah
which would stop the
$675 interest that grows each month oh
wow so my question is while I'm paying
off IRS right now and another smaller
debt um I should have those paid off at
the end of next month and the end of
January
should I be making the interest payment
on the medical debt to kind of hold the
balance where it is until I can get to
these other debts or not pay it and just
let it go up or how much um well the I
the the perfect scenario is that you're
staying current on it and not getting
behind on it so my question is um for
you're going to be done with one of the
debts end of this month is that correct
so how much money would that free up at
the end of this month end of no end of
uh December um I'll be IRS debt free and
put about I put about $2,300 a month
towards that okay so that'll be freed up
and then what about the January debt how
much do you pay on that the January debt
I'm um currently paying 675 a month on
okay and I was figuring I'll have it
paid off in January because I was going
to put the rest of the IRS money towards
that one y y and have it paid off in in
uh January and then what I'm left with
is the one that's not accepting payments
that's a private student loan that has
my dad's name on it so I've been trying
to prioritize that since March but
they're like they won't accept anything
and then I have a Chrysler um re
repossessed car debt that I also need to
tackle for 32,000 for 32
okay uh how much do you make a
year uh I take home about 100,000 okay
wow you've been doing a lot of work work
then I mean yeah you've you've killed it
um for the medical debt since it's in
collections have you tried to negotiate
that down at all I have and I feel like
they will they they say no that they
need the minimum payment or and they
actually lied to me for months and
months and said they can't accept
payments on it at all unless it's the
minimum amount which is a total lie I
called back and I clicked the numbers to
get to the pay one and all of a sudden
they said they would accept payments but
just not the minimum want to stop the
interest so um they totally lied to me
and I believed it so I forgot what your
question was no no you're good you're
good I was just
wondering uh because it's such a large
medical debt and it's in
collections most of the time they will
settle for but you you'll have to have
that amount of money usually to make
that deal possible so your question is
from now honestly um and I'll be curious
Ken your thoughts on this I I'm almost
tempted Britta to to attack these two
smaller ones especially the IRS one I
would want that out like ASAP yeah and
it's going to just free up three grand
so even if you get behind two to three
months um because on on the interest I
mean I would still try to pay the
minimum payment if you can and stay
current um but I I would yeah I think I
would focus a lot on my efforts on these
smaller ones get them knocked off that's
going to free up three grand are you
able to pay that minimum pay at all of
the 2300 with the medical or does that
does that slow down your entire Deb
snowball no I I could pay that um but it
would stop me paying off IRS right now
and then it would slow the other one
getting paid off in January yeah so I I
could put that towards it no problem but
I feel like in my conversations with
them that they will settle with me if I
have some sort of lump some payment to
give to them exactly the verbage they've
used makes me think that yes for sure
yeah and usually they will we find most
of the time they will uh you'd want to
get it in riding when that happens but
again I kind of want I want to clear up
the IRS stuff that I don't like the IRS
being around and 100% And then you're so
close with the other one to pay off so I
agree and I I would I agree with you
Rachel and but I would I would go the
step of BR I'd put a number out there
you cannot lose in this situation I'd
throw a number out I'd throw a lumps sum
number I'd go look this is what I can
pay you and this is when I can pay the
lump sum see what they say by the way
don't be don't be like crazy generous
you know like okay let's let's have some
fun with this this is like a stressfree
negotiation in my opinion you can't lose
so I'd throw a number out in fact let's
just talk about this really quick why
why would we what what's what's a number
that you have in your mind you go all
right I'll offer it this to them I'll
say here's the lump sum would you guys
be willing to settle for this and you
just put a number in front of them what
what would you
say well I was thinking if I was just
going to pay the interest until June I'm
expecting a bonus and I was thinking if
I'm just paying the interest and I'm
saving all this other back money up of
offering them 10,000 and them dropping
it to 50,000 I would be happy with that
I'm more than happy to pay my debt it's
my debt but even if they would you know
drop it down to 50,000 and then I could
pay that off next year no problem I'd
say that tell them go hey I want to pay
my debt I got into this mess I'm
cleaning it up this is what I'm
proposing and just see what they say yep
okay you could even go half you could
even go half on it BR sometimes some of
these it's like on the dollar I was
going to say even 40 yeah okay all right
thank you H yeah absolutely you know and
and when or start with this sorry to cut
you off but start with this hey what
would a lump sum what would you be
willing to receive from me on a lump
suum see what they throw out first yeah
yeah I kind of want them to show me
their cards totally sorry I I I no no
you're great you're great but I I
appreciate you know Brenda's um brda
brda gosh sorry BR I'm here for you
thank you sorry your name is not not
Brenda it is Brenda I'm sorry um I
appreciate her humility in it though
knowing like this is my debt cuz that's
part of this conversation when you sign
up for
it you owe it right so so that is an
important part of this but also you guys
on this journey and she was about to
file for bankruptcy I mean she she had a
pile of stuff she had medical IRS all of
it so there is a point when the debt it
gets sold and it's in collections and
these people I mean like she said they
lie to you I mean it's just it's a gross
industry and if you know hey this
interest is absolutely insane there is
not a moral U check that you need to
have to say yeah I'm going to see if I
can negotiate this bill down because
you're still owning that you signed up
for this right but and medical debts so
terrible it's like yeah I think it's one
of the worst it's one of the number one
causes of bankruptcy in America is
medical debt so piles up quickly and has
such negative stuff attached to it so I
think you know asking for that
negotiation and talking through that is
very acceptable and and just to ask and
like you said Ken throw it out there and
just see the worst they can say is no
but at that point talk to it but also BR
if you're still on the line listening
make sure you get it in writing like
have them email you immediately get the
name of the person you're talking to if
a deal is done get their name get their
phone number their extension how you can
reach them I mean make sure you get all
this that's a great point cuz once you
hang up with them it's like playing the
lottery to get the same person back on
the phone I promise I talked to a lady
named Phyllis
they're like I don't know where Phyllis
is not sure she's in the Arkansas uh
headquarters oh okay you know you're
right get it in writing and that's a
very good point get the person same but
let listen the negotiation something let
somebody else throw a number out first I
mean you can always go back and forth so
I like that throw it out but BR is
crushing it I want people to catch
something you know she said at the very
beginning Rachel she said I backed out
of bankruptcy and she said something to
the effect of I'm so glad I did so I
hope some people hear that that that's
not as easy and clean and simple as it
feels like no not at all and you guys if
you're enjoying the show will you help
us spread the word will you review leave
a review uh subscribe send these
episodes out to friends and family the
more that we get listeners and people
watching and seeing this show hopefully
the more help that we can get across
America and to be able to help so make
sure to share like subscribe for all the
videos and all things Ramsey Show and
Ramsey Network shows
um that is great help to us so thank you
guys so much for tuning
[Music]
in
welcome back to the ramsy show the
holidays are coming up you guys and if
you want a meaningful gift make sure to
go to ramsy solutions.com store we have
a lot of books there for our $12 sale
including two of Ken's books yes please
buy a lot of those as you think about
your loved ones this Christmas Seas
paycheck to purpose thank you very much
uh paycheck to purpose come on boy this
isar proximity principal so now we can
still be friends that was that was
hanging on a line there what are my two
uh your two are exactly uh kick them is
what they like to call it know yourself
know your money and uh before that over
there oh good friend I see oh wow I'm
really nervous all of a sudden wow uh
love your life not your
there good job there you go so those are
in the $12 sale along with a Total Money
Makeover baby steps millionaires we
don't need to mention anybody else's
yeah go check them out you guys and also
if you go to Ram solutions.com store
you'll see my new kids book I'm glad for
what I have make sure to check that out
for all the little ones in your life
look at that and it's almost like uh the
pages are are thick it's great quality
of a book too I'll point that out I'm
going to smell it oh oh fresh printing
yeah fresh fresh off the press is what
and this is lovely lots of cute wisdom
in this yes so make sure to check out
all those and again for the holiday
season get a gift that's going to help
somebody did you do audio on this by the
way you know Amilia did my daughter read
the book are you kidding me I know I
don't know if we're using it for like an
audio book per se but we're using it in
some of the like marketing and different
why not I want to talk to the big shot
who decided know on that and actually
Caroline was the intro and she says I'm
glad for what I have by wait wael
crows how is that not the audio book I'm
tell you if the people speak we're going
to release that I got to talk to Dave I
got yeah they got it they got it I'm G
send him an email oh so great so great I
know so fun so fun all right we're go to
the phones this hour and we got Anna
Marie in Albuquerque New Mexico hey Anna
Marie welcome to the show hi Hi how are
you we are doing great how can we help
um okay so I just want to give you a
quick bit of information because I might
have bearing on the answer you give um
so we did the baby steps um I have 1500
in my savings uh we paid off all our
debt besides the house um but I don't
know if you'll like where I have my uh
three to six months of expenses I have
20,000 in a non-retirement investment
account okay and then I have we're I'm
doing 15% of uh my retirement is going
into a simple IRA and part of it going
into I however my husband uh doesn't
have a retirement account um and then uh
the I let's see I'll move on so what
we're wanting to do instead of paying
off our home early we're looking to
maybe sell it and build a cheaper house
so that we can be completely debt-free
and then my husband can start getting
his retirement I know that sounds
backwards um but we paid $345 for our
house um last time it was appraise it
was about 472 and right now I know it's
a little higher in value it's we could
probably listed at 500k after talking to
a realtor and uh looking at comp and so
my question is should we list our house
now and use that money to start building
the new home or should we use some money
that we have saved to start to start
building the new home right now and then
sell our house later I don't know how
Market's going to be in the future yeah
um how much do you owe on the
house so we owe about 310 okay so you
would you would get out about
290 um how much are you uh anticipating
the second smaller house so the new
smaller cheaper house what are you
expecting that to
cost
so I'm expecting it around 150 to
175 uh it'll be actually on the property
right next door the property we live on
5 Acres it'll be the 5 Acres next door
we thought about doing a mobile home but
we're really talking about building a
ship uh shop house don't do a mobile
home I know I just feel like that'll
yeah I don't feel like that'll be good
do you own the land you're GNA build on
shop house um my my parents bought that
land anticipating building out there but
we're going to buy it from them so we'll
pay about you know 23,000 for the land I
I Rachel I don't see I don't see any any
reason why you wouldn't do this Anna
Maria I don't think it's confusing at
all I think you sell your current house
you take the savings from that what you
make on that to pay cash for this next
situation and you're you're done I I
would do that I don't see you go rent
you'd have to go rent somebody somewhere
for a year that's the hard part is where
would we live in the inter you just have
You' have to rent well you act like
there's no place to live in Albuquerque
you're not going to live in a box under
a
bridge yeah you'd have to go rent
somewhere find rynal where we're at well
you'd have to figure that out because I
think finding the rental all right I'm
pulling it up is going to be worth it to
be able to do this deal because you'll
be able to take the equity out of that
house build what you want and get the
land I mean all of it pretty much is
settled there with cash and what it's
going to force you to do Amar which I
think is great is it's going to force
you guys to stay on budget because with
building it always can start creeping up
but if you guys hold true and hold fast
that nope we're doing this with cash
we'll be completely debt free uh and
then yet and then doing and then your
husband needs to start retirement even
before you guys start building he why is
he not contributing to retirement right
now um well he was but he recently quit
uh his job and he was only there for a
couple years and before that he kind of
worked for himself okay and uh and now
he's kind of working for himself um but
but we have about
aund
140,000 that we could spend building the
house now because what whatever we're
going to probably you 14 as our morgage
hold on so we have about we have about
55,000 cash and then um we have some
Vehicles we're selling that's about
45,000 and um and here's another thing
is I don't want to use the college fund
or the money that's in my non-retirement
investment account to put towards the
house but without that we would have a
100,000 to to build you need to sell and
we could you need to sell your house and
you guys yes yep I would 100% how much
is it just you and your
husband yes well no we have a daughter
sorry she's seven but income wise yes me
and my husband okay so so how so so
you're in such a hurry to build this
thing and and your whole big excuse is
well it's hard to find rent are you in
the greater Albuquerque
area no we're actually in a rural area I
mean it's it's it's not the town of
Albuquerque it's it's in it's in New
Mexico but it's in a smaller town okay
but the renting thing but you can find a
place to yeah and it's only for a short
period of time small amount of time for
six 6 to8 months is what you guys are
doing and then you have all the cash
there's none of this while we got to
pull from this account and that account
I'm exhausted listening it's hard
because we'd have to move to a
completely different place and move
twice we're building right next to our
house for six months it doesn't sound
like you're going to take our advice so
that's okay for six months that's okay
for six months is what we're saying it's
six months it's not six years it's not
even a full year for six months so you
can commute to the build
make sure it's all going okay keep the
address so the so your child so your
daughter stays in the same school system
it's all okay but for six months that in
okay perfect well perfect she
homeschools it's great so again the
inconvenience the inconvenience of maybe
having to drive an extra 20 30 minutes
away is worth it just to do a cash deal
and that there's no debt there's no
banks involved there's nothing and you
guys you have it you have the equity in
your house to do it and not to mention
it's going to keep you guys on track
which I think is really important but
you guys need to be looking at this and
you're in a great spot I mean you guys
have you have money you have money you
have emergency fund the 55,000 it could
be your emergency fund don't touch that
you have some Investments here you're
doing your Roth you're all doing it
great you're just switching houses which
is a dream anamarie yeah that's a dream
people want they want that here's the
other thing anamarie you're just
assuming that everything's going to go
exactly the way you think it's going to
go well I just got news for you and
you're probably chuckling right now on
hold you know that doesn't happen and
this way if you do it the way we're
telling you to do it then there's no
stress yes there's a bit of
inconvenience but that's just part of
change anyway I I would just make this
clean and easy and I think the way to do
that is sell rent build move it's clean
easy I was stressed out listening to the
process you know and I don't want you to
be stressed out yeah you don't need to
be there's no need to be you guys have
done a great job by the way we're having
a little bit of fun there but you guys
have put yourself in a position to be
able to do this as R job absolutely
congratulations thanks for
[Music]
calling
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me in studio
this hour our scripture of the day comes
from Philippians
3:13-14 one thing I do forgetting what
is behind and straining toward what is
ahead I press on toward the goal to win
the prize for which God has called me
heavenward in Christ Jesus our quote of
the day from Mary K Ash never give up
because you never know if the next try
is going to be the one that
works there you go is that Mary Kay as
in the Mary Kay cosmetics oh there you
go she knows she has some good some good
quotes I'm sure with business got
herself a pink Cadillac too a pink is
that what that is did I get that right
oh boy I got nervous when I threw that
out there I was like good that was good
yep some Mary Kay sales is what those
people have done yes they have all right
so uh we're going to close out this hour
uh with Molly in Dallas hey Molly
welcome to the
show hi thank you so much for having me
I'm really excited to be on the show
right now oh I'm so glad well we're
excited to talk to you we're glad you
called how can we help thank you so much
I'm I have two questions regarding the
scenario that I'm in and I don't know
how much information is going to be
pertinent so the The Bare Bones right
now is that I am
currently working against an insurance a
car insurance company for a car accident
I was in it's five years ago this month
it's been forever good great I was not
at fault it's it's been terrible um but
I was not at fault their insured was
texting and driving and took three years
just to get back to like a medical
Baseline for me oh my gosh so I'm really
grateful I'm not disabled I'm really
grateful I didn't lose my a limb or lose
a life but I still on paper I will not
be healed from my injuries but I know
Jesus as my healer so I a't worried
about it so moving forward I'm
negotiating and they have agreed to
cover all of my medical treatment my
injuries and like all these medical
deaths that have racked up so I'm no
longer represented by an attorney but I
had an attorney working on my case so I
have all of my bills all of my leans
lined up and so they're offering
me just under 29,000 for medical bills
and lost wages and I come before you
today wondering about the best strategy
for negotiating the pain and suffering
aspect of it because they offered me
less than $5 a day for the last five
years and they're really really
lowballing in that area and I don't
really know how
to advocate for myself in a way that's
Stern but fair I don't know what
fairness looks like for that well that's
a great question um let me jump in on
the last part of that uh so the fairness
piece I I don't think that you're a
dishonest person so I think that fair is
you being honest about what your care is
going to cost and I think you if you're
going to represent yourself which I
don't recommend uh but if you're going
to then I think you got to come up with
a number based on
um and if I was in your situation and
we'd sit down we go okay all right um
what is my ongoing care if I've got some
physical therapy if I've got some
follow-ups here maybe some potential
procedures surgeries whatever that is to
the best of your ability you've got to
be able to put that out on paper and
You' got able to approve that and you
got doctors weighing in all that signing
off on that and that's how you would go
to the insurance company and go look
this $5 a day business whatever you're
going to come up with there let me just
tell you what my health care costs are
for continuing care that's where I would
start so that you actually it's not
about Fair it's about facts facts like
this is in fact what it's going to cost
you should be covering this but Rachel
I'm not a fan of trying to and listen I
am about as direct and I love a good
scrum I love a good fight for
righteousness and honesty and I'd love
to get on the phone with these morons
right I really would but even I don't
think that's right I think I need
somebody advocate for me who knows some
of the ins and outs it might be worth a
good attorney here who's willing to work
on a content meaning you get money then
you get paid yes right right do you have
you had an attorney in the past five
years Molly at all yes so I signed on
with an attorney and then after two
years he changed law practices so I went
with him and then about after a year of
him being there he left law entirely so
the practice that I went with inherited
my claim and it was not a good fit at
all so we negotiated to just be released
from our agreement with no leans to that
law firm okay all right but let me say
this I don't know if you've ever seen
the old movie and this is going to be
fun if Rachel's seen this or not she
loves when I go into the way back
machine grand grand Grandpa R oh thank
thank you very much let me put my
cardigan on for a second he's on all
right the cardigan is on what what uh
rain maker with Matt Damon let me tell
you who what I would be doing and I'm
being serious right now I would find me
some young personal injury lawyer who's
hungry I mean like their shoes aren't
shined yeah you know they don't know how
to tie a tie yet but they're sharp and
they're smart and they only get paid if
they go and get money for you now I'm
being a little dramatic but I would find
somebody who's hungry who who is sharp
and and they want to score because
you've got everything laid out they
could quickly get into the situation and
go oh we've got something here but I'd
interview two or three of these young
hungry lawyers uh somebody who's good
not a complete Bumpkin or somebody
that's you know has no idea how to tie
their shoes but I would find somebody
that's hungry and and and if they think
they've got a case here and they want to
prove something they want to make some
money uh I'd turn them loose on this
that's what I would be doing if I were
in your shoes I don't know Rachel yeah
because I think having an expert Molly I
mean instead of you having to do this I
can only imagine getting into legal
battles and paperwork and I mean it's a
it's a whole other world and you deserve
more I mean like you're looking at it
and you're like this doesn't make
mathematical sense to Ken's point it's
not you just being emotional about it
it's truly like my bills like this is
these are my bills because of this
accident and insurance is supposed to
cover them so I think bringing in
somebody to Ken's point is a is a really
good idea and I would because these
insurance companies for the most part
they're trying to get as little out pay
out as little as possible AB so this is
that's what they do and so for you to
actually get what's fair to you I mean
it's been five years that's exhausting
like I don't even know if you have the
energy to fight this any bit you know
what I mean anymore and so to get
somebody that is fresh on the case
they're looking at everything and
they're able to to really help you out
because that's we got to flip this Molly
you know why cuz these insurance
companies are going to kick the can down
the road to the point that they're just
hoping to delay and delay and delay and
DeLay So you'll stop you need a absolute
Pitbull rotweiler kind of lawyer who is
so up in their grill that they go let's
settle let's get done with this we're
tired of hearing from this lawyer you
got to flip the game and uh and and
somebody out there will do that for you
and you're World Dallas Metroplex the
Metro there's somebody out there who's
looking to make their Mark and I'd find
somebody who wants to make you their
their hero I really do that's what I
would do yeah oh for sure for sure
especially when you get into these Niche
areas you guys and in Molly's case
obviously is a very specific one with a
car accident insurance company all of it
but get people who live and breathe the
stuff we say the same thing if you're
doing your taxes if you're doing your
investing if you're going to be selling
your house you know we have ramsy
preferred um you know coaches to help
you even with your uh financial
situation all over the country and elps
with real estate like like find these
people in these areas to help you you
don't have to be the only one in your
entire life right if you're going to go
work out for the first time you hire a
personal trainer if there's stuff you're
working through in your personal life
you you know you you hire a therapist to
walk through like you find people who
are who are experts in this stuff and
that includes when you're in a situation
like Molly that an insurance company's
kind of bullying you and stringing you
along for five years and you don't get
the money that you need to cover
everything cuz like you said $29,000
over five years and through all the
medical stuff that you have
documentation of that's what you deserve
like that's the Justice in it and so I
think there's there's a there's power in
that having people that know what
they're doing by the way bringing this
back full circle rain maker rain maker
came out in 1997 I'm not a grandpa for
knowing that have you not seen the movie
have you not seen the movie I was going
to say when you said rain I was going to
say
I'll tell you what you're you're a big
reader you're a big reader denn Hoffman
Dennis Hoffman Dustin Hoffman shoot no
no it's Matt Damon and Danny DeVito I
just got I just got I got people like
unbelievable Rachel bless her heart hey
you know what let me tell you this
you're a you're a reader it's a John gam
novel so go get that you can go get it
at the library cuz you like to save a
buck or two and take that on the old uh
summer vacation that's Sharon ramsy that
you're not a library nope I'm not Sharon
your mother still checks out books at
the library yes God bless her she is a
treasure yes she's a treasure folks or
she'll give me a book and it's a library
in Minnesota I'm like where'd you get
this mom she like it a used book off
Amazon like God bless you Mom God bless
you awesome well thanks to everyone in
the booth thank you America for
listening Ken thank you for being a
great co-host you and we'll be
[Applause]
back
[Music]
[Applause]
oh